No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets. They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet. So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks Copilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs to help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going and which little extras make the dollar slice work.
没人会为了汉克的电子表格而去他的店里，他们去是因为那里有超赞的披萨。但最近，店里生意冷清。于是汉克决定重新推出1美元一片的披萨。他请微软Excel中的Copilot查看他的销售额和成本，看看自己是否负担得起。Copilot向汉克展示了资金的去向，以及哪些小细节能让1美元披萨的方案行得通。
Now, Hank has a line out the door. Hank makes the pizza. Co-Pilot handles the spreadsheets. Learn more at M365Copilot.com slash work. The following episode contains descriptions of sexual violence that some people may find disturbing. If you would rather not hear this type of content, please come back next week for a new episode. Thank you. Last summer, police in New York arrested architect Rex Heurman and charged him with a series of murders that took place on Long Island between 1996 and 2011.
现在，汉克的店门口排起了长队。汉克负责做披萨，Copilot负责处理电子表格。欲了解更多信息，请访问M365Copilot.com/work。以下节目包含一些人可能会感到不安的性暴力描述。如果您不想收听此类内容，请下周再来收听新的一期。谢谢。去年夏天，纽约警方逮捕了建筑师雷克斯·赫尔曼，并指控他在1996年至2011年间在长岛犯下了一系列谋杀案。
The arrest of the suspect in the so-called Gilgo Beach killing, appears to have closed one of the more recent chapters in the history of American serial killers. From Jeffrey Dahmer to Ted Bundy to Son of Sam, serial killers have long-inspired public fear and public fascination. What we wonder could drive someone to commit such crimes, and how do these people get away with murder for so long? Today we're going to talk with a forensic psychologist who studies serial killing. We will discuss what the research tells. us about serial murderers motivations and methods. Are they all psychopaths or sociopaths or something
所谓“吉尔戈海滩杀人案”嫌疑人的被捕，似乎为美国连环杀手史上最近的一个篇章画上了句号。从杰弗里·达默到泰德·邦迪，再到“山姆之子”，连环杀手长期以来既引发公众恐惧，又令人着迷。我们不禁好奇，是什么驱使一个人犯下如此罪行？这些人又是如何长期逍遥法外的？今天，我们将与一位研究连环杀手的法医心理学家进行交谈。我们将讨论研究告诉我们关于连环杀手的动机和手段的信息。他们都是精神病患者、反社会者，还是其他什么人？
else? What exactly do those terms mean? Do serial killers ever feel remorse for their actions? How common is serial murder and why do so many of us find it so fascinating? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Lewis Schlesinger, a professor of psychology at the John Jay College of Criminal Justice in New York. He has spent decades studying serial murder and is the co-principal investigator of a joint
这些术语到底意味着什么？连环杀手会对自己的行为感到悔恨吗？连环谋杀有多普遍？为什么我们这么多人觉得它如此引人入胜？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是纽约约翰杰伊刑事司法学院的心理学教授刘易斯·施莱辛格博士。他花了数十年时间研究连环谋杀案，并且是与联邦调查局行为科学部联合开展的一项研究项目的共同首席研究员，
research project with the FBI Behavioral Science Unit studying sexual and serial murder, rape, bias homicide, suicide by cop, and other extraordinary crimes. He is a board certified forensic psychologist and an APA fellow and has published many research articles and 10 books on the topics of homicide, sexual homicide, and criminal psychopathology. Dr. Schlesinger, thank you for joining me today. Thank you. Let's start with a definition of the term. What constitutes a serial killer and is there a minimum number of such killings that one has to commit
该项目研究性谋杀、连环谋杀、强奸、偏见杀人、警察协助自杀以及其他极端犯罪。他是一位获得委员会认证的法医心理学家和美国心理学会会员，在杀人、性杀人和犯罪心理病理学领域发表了许多研究文章和10本书。施莱辛格博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。谢谢。让我们从术语的定义开始。什么构成了连环杀手？一个人必须犯下多少起此类杀人案才能符合这个定义？
to meet the definition? Well, serial killer literally means killing. people in a series. Now, when you speak about that, you have to talk about what type of serial killer you're referring to because they're very, very different in terms of how they behave, their psychodynamics, what motivates them, and so on. The type of serial killer that we know most about and that what most people are interested in is the serial sexual murderer, like the Boston Strangler, BTK, Ted Bundy. Jack the Ripper, and you mentioned the Gilgo Beach guy more recently. But there's other types of
嗯，连环杀手字面意思就是在一系列事件中杀人。现在，当你谈到这一点时，你必须说明你指的是哪种类型的连环杀手，因为他们在行为方式、心理动力学、动机等方面有着非常、非常大的差异。我们最了解、也是大多数人最感兴趣的连环杀手类型是连环性杀手，比如波士顿绞杀手、BTK、泰德·邦迪、开膛手杰克，以及你刚才提到的吉尔戈海滩的那个人。但还有其他类型的
individuals that kill in a series. For example, there's contract killers that would kill people for money. It is a world of difference for someone who's killing a series of people for money versus someone killing it for sexual gratification. There's the healthcare serial killers. Those are people that go into a hospital, for example, and kill a number of people. Some are nurses, some are physicians that do that. Again, it's a very different type of dynamic. And if you go into any state prison or penitentiary in the United States, you're going to find a number of people throughout their criminal career who have killed more than one or two people during a robbery,
在一系列事件中杀人的人。例如，有为了钱而杀人的合同杀手。对于为了钱而杀害一系列人的人，与为了性满足而杀人的人相比，这有着天壤之别。还有医疗连环杀手。这些人进入医院，例如，杀害了许多人。有些是护士，有些是医生。同样，这是一种非常不同的动态。如果你走进美国的任何州立监狱或教养所，你会发现许多人在他们的犯罪生涯中，在抢劫、
some sort of felony thing and so on. So we have to keep it separate. Now, what most people are interested in and the serial sexual murders that you refer to in, introduction, Jeffrey Dahmerin, VTK, and those sorts of things, are the serial sexual murderers. And so let me just talk about that and define that a little bit so the audience understands what we're referring to. Most people can understand murder. Most people I don't have any problem understanding that.
某种重罪等过程中杀害了不止一两个人。所以我们必须把它们分开。现在，大多数人感兴趣的是我在介绍中提到的连环性谋杀，比如杰弗里·达默、BTK等等，这些都是连环性杀手。所以让我谈谈这一点并稍微定义一下，以便听众了解我们指的是什么。大多数人能理解谋杀。大多数人，我理解这一点没有任何问题。
But sexual murder is very difficult for the average person to wrap their arms around. And so the question is, what's going on with these people? Before we could talk about what's going on in their mind, we have to get a couple of definitions straight. Serial sexual murder is not listed as a parapheria in any of the diagnostic manuals, a parapheria being an abnormal sexual arousal pattern like pedophilia, attraction to children, fetishism, sexual arousal to non-living objects, and this sort of thing. So it's not listed in a diagnostic manual. And it's also not defined in statute. The murder is defined. in statute, but serial murder or serial sexual murder is not. Also, an important point with respect to this, and many, many people get this wrong, including non-clinical psychologists, the sociologists,
但性谋杀对普通人来说很难理解。所以问题是，这些人到底怎么了？在我们讨论他们的心理之前，我们必须先弄清楚几个定义。连环性谋杀在任何诊断手册中都没有被列为性欲倒错，性欲倒错是一种异常的性唤起模式，如恋童癖、对儿童的吸引力、恋物癖、对非生物的性唤起等等。所以它没有列在诊断手册中。它也没有在法规中定义。谋杀在法规中有定义，但连环谋杀或连环性谋杀则没有。此外，关于这一点有一个重要的观点，许多人，包括非临床心理学家、社会学家，
and so on, is there does not have to be intercourse in order for it to be sexual. Why? Because the violence takes the place of it. As a matter of fact, in many, many of these cases, there's no sexual penetration at all. In addition to complicating the problem, if that wasn't enough, is there's no national crime statistics on the number of serial sexual murders in the United States, and no country keeps these statistics. Now, Canada, for example, our neighbor to the North used to keep statistics on serial sexual murder, but their definition was very different. It was killing someone in the context of a sex crime. So in other words, they would commit a sex crime and then kill the victim so that they couldn't
等等，都搞错了，那就是为了性，并不一定非要有性交。为什么？因为暴力取代了它。事实上，在许多此类案件中，根本没有性插入。如果这还不够复杂的话，美国没有关于连环性谋杀数量的国家犯罪统计数据，也没有任何国家保留这些统计数据。现在，例如我们的北方邻国加拿大，过去曾保留过连环性谋杀的统计数据，但他们的定义非常不同。它是指在性犯罪背景下杀人。换句话说，他们会犯下性犯罪，然后杀害受害者，这样受害者就无法
turn them in. That's very, very different than killing someone for sexual gratification. Statistics Canada, which is comparable to our uniform crime reports, no longer categorizes sexual murder because I spoke to them recently about it. It just becomes too complicated. So serial sexual murder, this is somebody that is going out and killing. repetitively because the murder itself is sexually gratifying. Let me say a couple things about human sexuality first.
举报他们。这与为了性满足而杀人有着非常、非常大的不同。加拿大统计局，相当于我们的统一犯罪报告，不再对性谋杀进行分类，因为我最近和他们谈过这件事。这变得太复杂了。所以连环性谋杀，是指一个人因为谋杀本身能带来性满足而反复杀人。让我先说几点关于人类性行为的事情。
On one end of the continuum, you have heterosexuals, adults attracted to members of the opposite sex. On the other end of the continuum, you could have homosexuals, adults attracted to members of the same sex. But is that it for human sexuality? The answer is no. There's many, many, many shades of gray. In between there, there's also abnormal sexual arousal patterns.
在连续体的一端，你有异性恋者，即被异性成员吸引的成年人。在连续体的另一端，你可能有同性恋者，即被同性成员吸引的成年人。但人类性行为仅此而已吗？答案是否定的。中间有许多、许多、许多灰色地带。中间还有异常的性唤起模式。
As I mentioned, pedophilia, arousal to children. Infantophilia, sexual arousal to preverbal infants. Hebaphilia, sexual arousal to pubescent adolescents. And there's things like fetishism and exhibitionism and these sorts of things. In my view, the best way to understand serial sexual murder is another parapheria, another abnormal sexual arousal pattern. And specifically, in these cases, there's a fusion of sex and aggression so that the aggressive act itself is eroticized.
正如我提到的，恋童癖，对儿童的唤起。婴儿恋，对前语言期婴儿的性唤起。青春期前恋，对青春期前青少年的性唤起。还有像恋物癖、露阴癖等等。在我看来，理解连环性谋杀的最好方法是将其视为另一种性欲倒错，另一种异常的性唤起模式。具体来说，在这些案件中，性与攻击性融合在一起，使得攻击行为本身被色情化了。
It's stimulating. And so people look at this and say, okay, murder. Understand murder. I could even understand hatred of women, for example. Let's kill women. But what they can understand, which is very difficult to understand, is what they do at the crime scene with these victims. They very often leave the victim in a sexually degrading position with foreign object insertions, for example. And so why do they do it? And the answer to that question is
它是刺激性的。所以人们看着这个说，好吧，谋杀。我理解谋杀。我甚至可以理解对女性的仇恨，例如。让我们杀掉女性。但他们无法理解，也非常难以理解的是，他们在犯罪现场对这些受害者做了什么。他们经常把受害者留在一种性羞辱的姿势中，例如插入异物。那么他们为什么要这样做呢？这个问题的答案是
killing alone is not psychosexually sufficient. So they have to go above and beyond actually killing the person to get complete sexual gratification. And the sexual instinct itself is very, very strong. That's why, that's how God made us. So for example, in order for a woman to become pregnant, she had to run 20 miles, most women would say you run 20 miles. I can't be bothered. There'd be no species. But God was way too smart for that, right? So in order for propagation of the species, he made the sexual instinct very, very strong. And so most people have a sexual encounter. They don't say, well, that's good. I'm going to move on to something else now. They want to do it again and again. And so what you see is a compulsive, repetitive aspect to serial sexual murder.
仅仅杀人不足以满足心理性需求。所以他们必须在实际杀人之外更进一步，才能获得完全的性满足。性本能本身是非常、非常强烈的。这就是上帝创造我们的方式。例如，为了让女性怀孕，她必须跑20英里，大多数女性会说你跑20英里吧。我可没空。那样就不会有物种了。但上帝太聪明了，对吧？所以为了物种繁衍，他让性本能变得非常、非常强烈。所以大多数人有过一次性经历后，不会说，嗯，那很好。我现在要去做别的事情了。他们想一次又一次地做。所以你看到的是连环性谋杀中一种强迫性的、重复的方面。
Let me ask you this, though. What drives people to become serial sexual killers? I mean, how much do we really know about their motivations and are there any common personality traits? The answer is it's not due to trauma. It's not due to poor parenting. And it's not an American phenomenon. Serial sexual murder has been described as far back as the 1800s. As a matter of fact, the first person to describe in a scientific way in terms of case description was a psychiatrist in Germany named Richard von Kraft Ebbing. And his classic book is titled Psychopathia Sexualis. And there's a chapter in there where he describes almost everything that we know about sexual murder today was described in 1886 by Kraft Ebbing. Not 1986 in Quantico, Virginia,
不过，让我问你这个。是什么驱使人们成为连环性杀手？我的意思是，我们对他们的动机到底了解多少？有没有什么共同的人格特质？答案是，这不是由创伤引起的。这不是由糟糕的教养引起的。而且这也不是一种美国现象。连环性谋杀早在1800年代就被描述过了。事实上，第一个以科学方式描述它（就案例描述而言）的人是德国的一位精神病学家，名叫理查德·冯·克拉夫特-埃宾。他的经典著作名为《性精神病学》。书中有一章描述了我们今天所知的关于性谋杀的几乎所有内容，这些内容在1886年就被克拉夫特-埃宾描述过了。不是1986年在弗吉尼亚州的匡提科，
but 1886. And so why do they do it? Again, you find it in every country, in every culture from pre-modern times, and there's no evidence at all that it's increasing. I did a study on that, actually, notwithstanding what you might hear in the news. Now, why do they do it? The the best understanding I think we have at this point is that it's a biopsychosocial phenomenon, with, in my view, a heavy emphasis on neurobiology. Now, poor parenting, traumatic events, none of those things are helpful. That's for sure. But the number of people who've had horrible childhoods, who've had terrible parenting, who've been
而是1886年。那么他们为什么要这样做呢？同样，你在每个国家、每种文化中都能发现它，从前现代时期开始，而且根本没有证据表明它在增加。实际上，我对此做过一项研究，尽管你可能在新闻中听到过相反的说法。那么，他们为什么要这样做呢？我认为我们目前最好的理解是，这是一种生物-心理-社会现象，在我看来，重点在于神经生物学。现在，糟糕的教养、创伤性事件，这些都无济于事。这是肯定的。但是，那些有过可怕童年、受过糟糕教养、被
abused, they don't go out, become serial, sexual murderers. it's a very, very small amount of the population. And in order for somebody to become a serial sexual murder, I believe many things have to go wrong. For example, I said neurobiological. Is it hormonal? Is it chemical? Is it electrical? Is it a combination of those factors plus a head injury, plus trauma and poor parenting? And I think yes. I think the answer is yes. And that's why it's very, very small, the number of people that do it, it's always been around, and there's no evidence that it's increasing. Now, you hear different estimates, how many serial killers are there roaming around the country? The FBI has never put out an official statement with respect to it. It's
虐待过的人，他们并没有走出去成为连环性杀手。这只是人口中非常、非常小的一部分。为了让某人成为连环性杀手，我相信很多事情必须出错。例如，我说了神经生物学。是荷尔蒙吗？是化学物质吗？是电信号吗？是这些因素加上头部受伤、加上创伤和糟糕教养的组合吗？我认为是的。我认为答案是肯定的。这就是为什么做这件事的人数非常、非常少，它一直存在，而且没有证据表明它在增加。现在，你听到不同的估计，全国有多少连环杀手在游荡？联邦调查局从未就此发表过官方声明。这
basically unknown, and I think unknowable actually. Let me just say one other thing to answer your question specifically with respect to our understanding of, you know, you. you said personality traits and so on. If you look, serial sexual murder is very popularized. I mean, you can't turn on one of the TV stations every night on one of the, you're going to see a crime documentary on this serial, that serial and so on. But if you look at the peer-reviewed publications in scientific journals in the past 20 years for popularized mental disorders like bipolar disorder, PTSD, eating disorders, you know, those are popularized too. there's between 60 and 75,000 articles on each of those disorders.
基本上是未知的，而且我认为实际上是不可知的。让我再说一件事来专门回答你关于我们对……你提到的性格特征等方面的理解的问题。如果你看的话，连环性谋杀非常大众化。我的意思是，你每天晚上打开电视频道，你都会看到关于这个连环杀手、那个连环杀手的犯罪纪录片等等。但如果你看看过去20年科学期刊中关于大众化精神障碍（如双相情感障碍、创伤后应激障碍、饮食失调，你知道，这些也很受欢迎）的同行评审出版物，
Do you know how many peer-reviewed published articles there have been? Empirical study now of serial sexual murder in the past 20 years? No, you don't know. I don't. It's a tiny number, yes. 22. And how many of those did you write? A number.
每种障碍都有6万到7.5万篇文章。你知道有多少篇同行评审发表的文章吗？现在对连环性谋杀的实证研究，在过去20年里？不，你不知道。我也不知道。是一个很小的数字，是的。22篇。你写了多少篇？几篇。
It was 21, but my latest publication made a 22. just came out a couple months ago. And so, you know, it's hard to answer your question definitively. But I can say this with respect to personality traits, and that's interesting as well. There's generally two types of individuals who commit sexual murder. Some do it in a very planned fashion where they try to elude law enforcement. They're forensically aware. And they leave crime scenes that are generally without a lot of physical evidence.
是21篇，但我最新的出版物凑成了22篇。几个月前刚出来。所以，你知道，很难明确回答你的问题。但我可以就性格特征说这一点，这也很有趣。犯下性谋杀的人通常有两种类型。有些人以非常有计划的方式行事，试图逃避执法。他们具有法医意识。他们留下的犯罪现场通常没有太多物证。
If you look at it visually, you'll see him as very organized. The murder weapon is taken with them, if it's a ligature strangulation, for example. The room itself is not all broken up with furniture. There's no blood of the offender on the victim. And so that's one type of offender, and he usually does it in a series which is thawed out. Now, there's another group that acts out more spontaneously. Now, why? It's because the underlying personality disturbance of that group is much more disturbed.
如果你从视觉上看，你会觉得他非常有组织。凶器随身带走，如果是勒死的话，例如。房间本身没有被家具弄得乱七八糟。受害者身上没有罪犯的血迹。所以这是其中一种罪犯，他通常会以一种被冷处理的方式进行一系列杀人。现在，还有另一群人表现得更自发。为什么？因为那群人的潜在人格障碍更严重。
If you look at people that kill one or two serial, sexual, and then they're caught, these are people that have borderline personality, schizophrenia, schizotypal personality. That's a severe personality disorder. For example, what's the problem? The problem is that type of disorder, psychopathology, mental disorder, does not allow allow the person to inhibit their impulses. So when they see, for example, a victim that crosses their path, they strike out. And if you strike out impulsively, there may be witnesses around, you leave forensic evidence around, you didn't plan on killing anybody, and you're apprehended
如果你看那些杀了一两个连环性受害者然后被抓的人，这些人患有边缘性人格障碍、精神分裂症、分裂型人格障碍。这是一种严重的人格障碍。例如，问题是什么？问题是那种障碍、精神病理学、精神障碍，不允许人抑制他们的冲动。所以当他们看到，例如，一个穿过他们路径的受害者时，他们就会出击。如果你冲动地出击，周围可能有目击者，你会留下法医证据，你并没有计划杀任何人，然后你被迅速逮捕了。
quickly. The other type has more what's often called psychopathic traits, narcissistic traits and whatever personality they have, it doesn't disable them from planning. You could be narcissistic, you could be psychopathic, but you can still plan and inhibit your impulses. And that's what you see in those sorts of cases. And as a result, because they're forensically aware and they can plan, they can rack up a very high number of victims. Those are the cases that the FBI usually becomes involved in. Why? Because the FBI's called in, you almost always, when it's a difficult to solve case. Otherwise, if it's just one murder or two, local law enforcement can usually make the apprehension. So you mentioned psychopathy, but I'm wondering about sociopath. I mean, are these people,
另一种类型有更多通常被称为精神病态特征、自恋特征，无论他们有什么人格，都不会妨碍他们进行计划。你可以是自恋的，你可以是精神病态的，但你仍然可以计划并抑制你的冲动。这就是你在那些案件中看到的。结果，因为他们有法医意识并且可以计划，他们可以积累非常多的受害者。这些是联邦调查局通常介入的案件。为什么？因为联邦调查局几乎总是在案件难以解决时才被叫去。否则，如果只是一两起谋杀案，当地执法部门通常可以进行逮捕。所以你提到了精神病态，但我对反社会者感到好奇。我的意思是，这些人是
sociopaths, psychopaths, what's the difference? Can you be one and not the other? Yes. Yes. Let me talk about three different terms, psychopathic personality. sociopathic and antisocial personality disorder because they get kind of mushed together particularly when you speak about these things and people refer to and so on the only official diagnosis in the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental disorders that's the manual that psychologists psychiatrists and so on rely on is antisocial personality disorder that's been the official diagnosis for years sociopathic personality was in the manual back in the 1950s but it has since been eliminated.
反社会者、精神病患者，有什么区别？你可以是其中之一而不是另一个吗？是的。是的。让我谈谈三个不同的术语：精神病态人格、反社会人格和反社会人格障碍，因为它们在谈论这些事情时被混为一谈了。精神疾病诊断与统计手册（这是心理学家、精神病学家等依赖的手册）中唯一的官方诊断是反社会人格障碍，这是多年来的官方诊断。反社会人格在1950年代的手册中出现过，但后来被删除了。
Interestingly, when someone pontificates about these sorts of things, they'll always say he's a psychopath. He's a psychopath. Right. Psychopathic personality is time honored. It's been around since the 1800s when some of the early alienists, which what they called psychiatrists back in the turn of the last century, was called moral insanity, moral imbecility and so on. And it's always been in the literature. It's been in the psychiatric literature.
有趣的是，当有人对这些事情发表高论时，他们总是会说他是个精神病患者。他是个精神病患者。没错。精神病态人格是久经考验的。它自1800年代以来就一直存在，当时一些早期的异见者（这是上世纪之交他们对精神病学家的称呼）称之为道德疯狂、道德痴呆等等。它一直存在于文献中。它存在于精神病学文献中。
It's been in the psychoanalytic literature. It's been in the psychological literature. But it's never been an official diagnosis. And so, but what is generally meant by psychopath is somebody who outwardly appears normal. They have what Hervey Cleckley called a mask of sanity. They can cover up the underlying disturbance. And the underlying disturbance is a lack of. of emotional attachment to other people. That's what makes us human. We have attachments to other people.
它存在于精神分析文献中。它存在于心理学文献中。但它从来不是一个官方诊断。那么，精神病患者通常指的是什么？是指外表看起来正常的人。他们拥有赫维·克莱克利所说的“理智的面具”。他们可以掩盖潜在的障碍。而潜在的障碍是对他人缺乏情感依恋。这就是使我们成为人类的原因。我们对他人的依恋。
The psychopath in a general and a Clekleyan sense does not have that. They're devoid of that. And so they can cut off a person just like that. So that was a Cleckley's conception. And it's used a lot. Now, why is it used in serial killing? Why do you hear people say he's a psychopath? He's a psychopath. psychopathy does not make you go out and kill people for sexual gratification. It doesn't. What it does do is it determines how the murder is carried out. So if you have a psychopathic personality and you also have a sexual arousal pattern where there's a fusion of sex and aggression so that the aggressive act itself is eroticized, then you can plan your crime. And if you can plan your crime, And if you can plan your crime and you're forensically aware, you can allude law enforcement
克莱克利意义上的精神病患者没有那种东西。他们缺乏那种东西。所以他们可以就这样切断与一个人的联系。这就是克莱克利的构想。它被广泛使用。现在，为什么它在连环杀人案中使用？为什么你听到人们说他是个精神病患者？他是个精神病患者。精神病态并不会让你为了性满足而去杀人。它不会。它所做的是决定了谋杀是如何进行的。所以如果你有精神病态人格，并且你也有一个性与攻击性融合的性唤起模式，使得攻击行为本身被色情化，那么你就可以计划你的犯罪。如果你可以计划你的犯罪，并且你有法医意识，你就可以逃避执法，
and rack up a high number of victims. And that's the answer to that. It's not causative. A personality disorder does not cause anybody to go out and kill women against sexual gratification. It determines on how they go about doing it. Now, that leads to the question of remorse or even regret. I mean, do such people feel remorse? Do they regret or are they only?
并积累大量的受害者。这就是答案。它不是致病因素。人格障碍不会导致任何人为了性满足而去杀害女性。它决定了他们如何去做。现在，这引出了悔恨甚至遗憾的问题。我的意思是，这些人会感到悔恨吗？他们会后悔吗？还是他们只有在被抓时才感到
remorseful when they get caught. Well, that's a very difficult determination, how you determine if somebody is remorseful or not. Now, if you see any old criminal in prison, which I've been doing for 48 years now, almost all of them, not everyone, but almost all of them will say, oh, I never should have done it. I feel bad, I saw a terrible thing and so on. So it's very difficult to determine. The serial sexual murderer usually does not feel any type of remorse. towards the victim himself. And I keep saying himself because these are 99.99% men killing women, generally speaking. So no, these are people, again, as Cleckley said, they're devoid of human emotion. They have trouble with empathy. Interestingly enough, enough, although they don't have bonding to other people, many people attach themselves to the psychopath. And that's why you see many psychopaths have an entourage following them around, hangers on, and this type of thing. Well, you know, I mentioned Rex Hewerman in my intro. He was married. I mean, how is that unusual for a serial sexual killer to actually have a marital relationship? No, that's not uncommon.
悔恨？嗯，这是一个非常困难的判断，你如何判断某人是否悔恨。现在，如果你在监狱里看到任何老罪犯，我已经这样做了48年了，几乎所有人，不是每个人，但几乎所有人都会说，哦，我真不该那样做。我感觉很糟糕，我做了一件可怕的事情等等。所以很难判断。连环性杀手通常不会对受害者本人感到任何形式的悔恨。我一直说“他”，因为这些99.99%是男人杀害女性，总的来说。所以不，这些人，正如克莱克利所说，他们缺乏人类情感。他们在同理心方面有困难。有趣的是，尽管他们没有与他人的联结，但许多人却依附于精神病患者。这就是为什么你看到许多精神病患者身边有一群随从、追随者等等。嗯，你知道，我在介绍中提到了雷克斯·赫尔曼。他结婚了。我的意思是，连环性杀手有婚姻关系这不寻常吗？不，这并不罕见。
That's not uncommon for the serial sexual murder who plans his crimes because he has the type of personality that's generally speaking, not off-putting. They look normal. They have a mask of normality. They can speak. They can engage and so on. The other type of sexual murder who's much more disturbed very often is not married. Any type of, you know, sexual involvement is often with a sex worker. They very often live with a parent and so on.
对于计划犯罪的连环性杀手来说，这并不罕见，因为他拥有的人格类型通常来说并不令人反感。他们看起来很正常。他们有正常人的面具。他们可以说话。他们可以参与等等。另一种更受困扰的性杀手通常没有结婚。任何类型的性参与通常都是与性工作者。他们经常与父母住在一起等等。
But those individuals that you see with a high number of victims very often are married or in a committed relationship at the time. And the partner, the wife, usually says things like, I knew something was odd about him or weird, but I never dreamed that he would be going around killing people. Right. Now, you say to yourself, now when you hear this, you say, oh, come on, you live with this guy. This has been reported from Kraft Ebbing's time back in the 1800s. because how would you know to think that your partner is weird is one thing, but to think that he's going out killing people is such an alien thought and it's so remote. And that's what so many of the women say who are subsequently interviewed.
但那些你看到的受害者人数众多的个体，通常在当时已婚或处于承诺关系中。而伴侣，妻子，通常会说诸如“我知道他有点奇怪”之类的话，但我从没想过他会到处杀人。对。现在，你对自己说，当你听到这个时，你会说，哦，得了吧，你和这家伙住在一起。这从1800年代克拉夫特-埃宾时代就有报道。因为你怎么会知道呢？认为你的伴侣很奇怪是一回事，但认为他出去杀人是一个如此陌生的想法，而且太遥远了。这就是后来接受采访的许多女性所说的。
Some serial sexual murderers, like the Boston Strangler, for example, was generally speaking a fairly good husband and he was a good parent. I mean, the children of a lot of them said, you know, my father is a fairly normal guy. He did this. He did that. And so on. Dennis Raider, B.T.K.'s wife, had no idea at all. As a matter of fact, the police who interacted with her said she's just a very, very nice person. And, you know, and he raised a family and had a fairly responsible position. So it's, this is way more complicated, this type of disorder than, for example, depressive. or PTSD and that sort of thing. This is very complicated. And I know that, let me say this a couple of things. The American people want their serial killers to be evil geniuses with IQs of 180, who speak five languages, including Aramaic, who are connoisseurs of fine wine, like Hannibal Lecter. Nothing could be further from the truth. Nothing could be further from the truth. And even those very few offenders who went to college, for example, and
一些连环性杀手，比如波士顿绞杀手，总的来说是一个相当好的丈夫，他是一个好父亲。我的意思是，很多人的孩子说，你知道，我父亲是一个相当正常的人。他做了这个。他做了那个等等。丹尼斯·雷德，BTK的妻子，根本不知道。事实上，与她互动的警察说她只是一个非常、非常善良的人。而且，你知道，他抚养了一个家庭，并担任了一个相当负责任的职位。所以，这比抑郁症或创伤后应激障碍等要复杂得多。这非常复杂。我知道，让我说几件事。美国人民希望他们的连环杀手是智商180、会说五种语言（包括阿拉姆语）、是像汉尼拔·莱克特那样的美酒鉴赏家的邪恶天才。事实远非如此。事实远非如此。即使是那极少数上过大学的罪犯，例如，
had a degree, Bundy, you mentioned the Gilgo Beach guy, and so they really don't use their intelligence as far as I can determine in any really, really productive way in carrying out their murders. Because we had the case up in the Pacific Northwest of Gary Ridgeway, they called them the Green River Killer. You know, he eluded law enforcement for over 20 years. His IQ was 83. You know, and so now you say, you know, why is that? Well, I'll tell you a couple of reasons. The hardest thing, let me say it this way, the hardest thing for a serial killer is the abduction. How do you get a woman to go with you? That's not so simple. And so that's why you see sex workers are very often targeted. Part of their job description is to go with a stranger, have sex, take your clothes off, usually in a remote area. Also, if a sex worker turns up dead, you don't know who are. what her real identity is. She's known on the street by a street name, and she may have been killed in New York, but she could be from Chicago or Florida or anywhere. So it's very, very, very difficult. And that's why you see those women are targeted.
拥有学位，邦迪，你提到了吉尔戈海滩的那个人，他们真的没有以任何真正有效的方式利用他们的智力来实施谋杀。因为我们在太平洋西北地区有加里·里奇韦的案件，他们称他为绿河杀手。你知道，他逃避执法超过20年。他的智商是83。你知道，所以现在你说，你知道，为什么会这样？嗯，我会告诉你几个原因。最难的事情，让我这样说，对连环杀手来说最难的是绑架。你怎么让一个女人跟你走？这并不简单。这就是为什么你看到性工作者经常成为目标。她们工作描述的一部分就是和一个陌生人走，发生性关系，脱掉衣服，通常是在偏远地区。此外，如果一名性工作者被发现死亡，你不知道她的真实身份是什么。她在街上以街头名字闻名，她可能是在纽约被杀的，但她可能来自芝加哥或佛罗里达或任何地方。所以这非常、非常、非常困难。这就是为什么你看到那些女性成为目标。
You thought this was your run club era. Turns out it was more of a thinking about run club era. The good news? Someone's marathon training is about to start. Sell your workout gear on Dpop. Just snap a few photos and we'll take care of the rest. They get their race day fit and you get a payout for trying. Someone on Dpop wants what you've got. Start selling now. Deepop where Taste recognizes taste.
你以为这是你的跑步俱乐部时代。结果发现这更多是关于跑步俱乐部的思考时代。好消息？某人的马拉松训练即将开始。在Dpop上卖掉你的健身装备。只需拍几张照片，剩下的交给我们。他们得到比赛日的装备，你得到尝试的回报。Dpop上有人想要你拥有的东西。现在开始销售。Deepop，品味识别品味的地方。
So what about female serial killers? Are they sexual serial killers, first of all? And is their profile similar to that of male serial killers? Well, female serial sexual murderers are generally non-existent. Now, there was a woman in Florida, Aline Warnis, who killed a bunch of men, but she was a sex worker. She hated men. She just killed men for the motivation of just revenge or something like that. And that was actually studied and a paper published on that as well.
那么女性连环杀手呢？首先，她们是性连环杀手吗？她们的特征与男性连环杀手相似吗？嗯，女性连环性杀手通常不存在。现在，佛罗里达州有一个女人，艾琳·沃诺斯，她杀了一群男人，但她是一名性工作者。她恨男人。她只是为了复仇或类似的事情而杀人。这实际上也经过了研究，并发表了一篇关于此的论文。
Yes, she killed in a series. So literally she was a serial killer, but the motivation was not sexual. Yeah, it's really a different thing. Again, keep in mind, in the past 20 years, we only have 22 publications on this. And so a lot of what you hear said is coming from folklore and Silence of the Lambs and people repeating these sorts of things, which can be dangerous in an investigation because serial sexual murderers, those who read the newspapers and follow the news, and they hear somebody pontificating about this may change their plan, may change their MO, the method of operation.
是的，她在一系列事件中杀人。所以从字面上看，她是一个连环杀手，但动机不是性的。是的，这确实是另一回事。再次提醒，在过去20年里，我们只有22篇关于此的出版物。所以你听到的大部分内容来自民间传说和《沉默的羔羊》，以及人们重复这些事情，这在调查中可能是危险的，因为连环性杀手，那些阅读报纸并关注新闻的人，听到有人对此发表高论可能会改变他们的计划，可能会改变他们的作案手法（MO）。
We saw a good example of that about 10 years ago, I think, in Washington, D.C. We had the D.C. sniper. It was a guy with a young, I think 17-year-old juvenile with him. going around shooting people. And there were people pontificating on TV about the signature, the signature. Now, they got that from the serial killer routine. And then there was someone else talking about geographic profiling and where they, and so the next murder that weekend was 90 miles away. It was outside of the D.C. area, which makes the investigation so much more difficult. Now you've got a tri-state area as opposed to a small area. Right. So these sorts of things
我们大约10年前在华盛顿特区看到了一个很好的例子。我们有特区狙击手。那是一个年轻人，我想是一个17岁的少年和他在一起。到处射杀人。电视上有人在谈论签名，签名。现在，他们是从连环杀手常规中得到的。然后还有人在谈论地理侧写以及他们在哪里，所以那个周末的下一次谋杀发生在90英里外。它在特区区域之外，这使得调查变得更加困难。现在你有一个三州地区，而不是一个小区域。对。所以这些事情
really don't help. But is there a, does there tend to be a signature in these types of serial sexual killings? I mean, part of the reason that Son of Sam got caught, I mean, there were a lot of reasons, but he did keep looking for the same type of woman to the point where women who lived in Brooklyn were wearing blonde wigs, you know, that sort of thing. Right. So are there signatures?
真的没有帮助。但是，在这些类型的连环性杀人案中是否存在签名？我的意思是，“山姆之子”被抓的部分原因，我的意思是，有很多原因，但他确实一直在寻找同一类型的女性，以至于住在布鲁克林的女性戴着金发假发，你知道，那种事情。对。所以有签名吗？
Oh, well, let me, let me say this. I did the only research study, empirical study, on ritual and signature in serial sexual. murder. It was published in the Journal of the American Academy of Psychiatry in Law back in 2010. And what we found is, notwithstanding Silence of the Lambs and Hannibal Lecter, who was talking about putting a moth or butterfly in the mouth of all these women, it's way more complicated than that. They do behave in ritualistic ways, but not exact ways. And let me say two things of our study without getting into the weeds that I think people will find interesting is one thing is that their behavior at a crime scene tends to evolve. And so the more comfort they have in killing, the more
哦，嗯，让我，让我说这个。我做了唯一的研究，关于连环性谋杀中仪式和签名的实证研究。它于2010年发表在《美国精神病学与法律学会杂志》上。我们发现，尽管有《沉默的羔羊》和汉尼拔·莱克特（他在谈论把飞蛾或蝴蝶放在所有这些女人的嘴里），但这比那复杂得多。他们的确以仪式化的方式行事，但不是确切的方式。让我说两件关于我们研究的事情，而不深入细节，我认为人们会觉得有趣，一件事是他们在犯罪现场的行为往往会演变。所以他们杀人越舒服，
elaborate their behavior at a crime scene will become. So initial torture, initial torture becomes much more elaborate torture later on. But the most important finding that we found is that in 70% of the cases, a serial killer does something with one victim in a series that he does not do with others in a series. For example, if they link five women in a series together, they're linked for some reason. And you look at the five women, four of the bodies are just dumped with no clothes on. But one body is mutilated in some way. Her breasts are cut off, there's something shoved in or that type of thing. You look at the average homicide detective with 25 years of experience.
他们在犯罪现场的行为就会变得越复杂。所以最初的折磨，最初的折磨后来会变成更复杂的折磨。但我们发现的最重要的发现是，在70%的案件中，连环杀手对系列中的一个受害者所做的事情，他不会对系列中的其他人做。例如，如果他们将五个女人联系在一起，她们因为某种原因被联系在一起。你看着这五个女人，四具尸体只是被扔在那里，没有穿衣服。但一具尸体以某种方式被肢解了。她的乳房被切掉，有什么东西被塞进去等等。你看着一个有25年经验的普通凶杀案侦探。
They're going to say, that's a different guy. Look at his behavior. What he did with that victim, that's not true. And you would only know that if you studied a high number of these cases, which most don't. The FBI does, I do. And there's a couple of people in the country affiliated with the FBI that studies these sorts of things. But it's counterintuitive. And so we found in 70% of the cases, an offender will do something with one victim that he did not do with others in the series.
他们会说，那是另一个人。看看他的行为。他对那个受害者所做的事情，那不是真的。只有当你研究了大量这些案件时，你才会知道这一点，大多数人不会。联邦调查局会，我会。全国有几个人隶属于联邦调查局，研究这些事情。但这违反直觉。所以我们发现，在70%的案件中，罪犯会对一个受害者做一些他不会对系列中其他人做的事情。
So then we asked the question, well, where does he do it in the series? In the beginning, the middle or the end? We thought in the end. Once he gains more comfort, he'll experiment at a crime scene and do something different. Not true. One third do it in the beginning. One third do it in the middle. And one third do it in the end.
所以我们问了一个问题，嗯，他在系列中的什么地方做这件事？开始、中间还是结束？我们以为是在最后。一旦他获得了更多的舒适感，他就会在犯罪现场进行实验并做一些不同的事情。不是真的。三分之一在开始时做。三分之一在中间做。三分之一在最后做。
That's why you have to do the research rather than just rely on popular culture and this sort of thing. But is it even possible to come up with an accurate profile? Because it sounds like that's what you're trying to help with when there are so few cases. And there is this level of variety. Yeah, there is. And let me say it this way. You can come up with some sort of quote unquote profile, but not to go to court and link them with, link those crimes because there's no scientific evidence that would pass the legal
这就是为什么你必须做研究，而不是仅仅依赖流行文化等等。但是，甚至有可能得出一个准确的特征吗？因为听起来当你只有这么少的案例时，你正在试图帮助解决这个问题。而且存在这种多样性。是的，确实存在。让我这样说。你可以得出一个所谓的“特征”，但不能去法庭并将它们联系起来，联系那些罪行，因为没有科学证据可以通过法律
standard for the admissibility of scientific evidence, which is either called the Frye standard, is it generally accepted, or the Daubert standard, meaning is it more than generally accepted, is it empirically supported, published in peer review journals and all the rest? The point of the Dowbert standard is to keep junk science out of the courtroom. And so you can use a quote unquote profile in an investigation, but to go to court and say, this guy killed these five people based on behavior, there's only one study. It's my study, basically. And that's just not enough to meet the legal standard. Earlier, I think you indicated that there may be some biosocial thing thing going on with people who become serial sexual killers. Has any study been done into the brains of
标准来证明科学证据的可采性，这要么被称为弗莱标准（它是否被普遍接受），要么是道伯特标准（意味着它是否不仅仅被普遍接受，它是否得到实证支持，发表在同行评审期刊上等等）。道伯特标准的重点是将伪科学排除在法庭之外。所以你可以在调查中使用所谓的“特征”，但去法庭说，根据行为，这家伙杀了这五个人，只有一个研究。基本上是我的研究。这不足以达到法律标准。早些时候，我想你指出，那些成为连环性杀手的人可能存在某种生物社会因素。有没有对这些人的大脑进行过研究
these people to better understand what is going on that's different? The answer is nothing really definitive at this point for a number of reasons. There's so few cases, number one. Number two, to study their brains, they're going to have to get their permission to become somewhat invasive. And a lot of these guys are just not doing that. There are some people that are looking at. There are looking at cat scans and pet scans and MRIs and trying to come up with something, but it's very, very difficult because of the number of cases. There just aren't that many cases around and there's not that many cases accessible. As I mentioned before, if you want to study PTSD, easy to get cases. Go to a VA hospital. You want to study alcoholism. Go to a rehab center. You want to study
以更好地了解发生了什么不同？答案是目前还没有真正确定的结论，原因有很多。案例太少了，第一。第二，要研究他们的大脑，他们必须获得许可才能进行某种侵入性操作。而这些人中的许多人根本不这样做。有些人正在观察。他们正在观察CT扫描、PET扫描和MRI，并试图得出一些结论，但这非常、非常困难，因为案例数量的原因。根本没有那么多案例，也没有那么多可访问的案例。正如我之前提到的，如果你想研究创伤后应激障碍，很容易获得案例。去退伍军人医院。你想研究酗酒。去康复中心。你想研究
bipolar disorder. Go to a psychiatric hospital. You want to study serial, sexual murder. Where are you going to get the cases? If you're not connected, with the FBI who has a national reach, it's very, very difficult to do this. And at John Jay, we've had about a 20-year relationship with the FBI behavioral analysis unit down in Quantico, and we're continuing to do this research and so on. I'll tell you, one interesting finding that was just published a couple of weeks ago in the Journal of Forensic Sciences is you would think that these individuals would have a history of sexual assault or rape in their background. They don't. And so I look very carefully at these studies.
双相情感障碍。去精神病院。你想研究连环性谋杀。你要去哪里找案例？如果你没有与拥有全国影响力的联邦调查局建立联系，这非常、非常困难。在约翰杰伊，我们与匡提科的联邦调查局行为分析部门建立了大约20年的关系，我们正在继续进行这项研究等等。我告诉你，几周前在《法医科学杂志》上发表的一个有趣的发现是，你可能会认为这些人背景中有性侵犯或强奸史。他们没有。所以我非常仔细地研究了这些研究。
Going back to Kraft Ebbing, even Kraft Ebbing described medical abnormalities, family histories, prior arrests, all sorts of characteristics, but didn't describe one case of a history of sexual assault or rape. So we found, in our cases, 26% of the offenders have a history of sexual assault right, which means that three-fourths of them don't, but we found something very important that will help in an investigation. That is, if an offender sexually penetrated a homicide victim in their series, there's about an 80% chance he had a likelihood of a conviction in its rap sheet of sexual assault rape. That helps enormously in an investigation. Because other things that we know in the background of serial sexual murders, such as inappropriate maternal sexual
回到克拉夫特·埃宾（Kraft Ebbing），即使是他也描述了医学异常、家族史、既往逮捕记录以及各种特征，但从未描述过一个有性侵犯或强奸史的案例。因此，我们在自己的案例中发现，26%的罪犯有性侵犯史，这意味着四分之三的人没有。但我们发现了一些对调查非常有帮助的重要信息。也就是说，如果罪犯在系列案件中对凶杀受害者进行了性侵犯，那么他的犯罪记录中存在性侵犯或强奸定罪的可能性约为80%。这对调查有巨大的帮助。因为我们在连环性谋杀背景中了解到的其他情况，例如成长过程中不适当的母亲性
conduct in their upbringing, a sadistic fantasy, animal cruelty, other types of mental health disorders are not going to be available to an investigator in an investigation. Once you get a suspect, you can get to mental health records, and that might be available then. But in investigation, you only have his rap sheet. And so if one in the series is sexually penetrated, that's close to an 80% likelihood that he had sexual assault in his rap sheet. And it really helps the investigation a lot. Do serial sexual killers as a rule desire to become famous, even as they need to hide
行为、虐待狂幻想、虐待动物以及其他类型的心理健康障碍，在调查初期是无法提供给调查人员的。一旦你锁定了嫌疑人，你或许可以获取心理健康记录，但在此之前，你只有他的犯罪记录。所以，如果系列案件中有一例涉及性侵犯，那么他犯罪记录中有性侵犯的可能性接近80%。这确实对调查有很大帮助。连环性杀手通常渴望出名吗，即使他们需要隐藏
their identity so that they can keep killing? I mean, how much of a motivator is that? No, that's been overhyped right from the beginning. There's so much of this is overhyped that he's playing with the police. He's toying with the investigation. He's sitting in his room and, you know, rolling his hands. No, they do not want to get caught, but very often they will do things that almost ensure that they'll get caught. Take, for example, Dennis Rader, the BTA guy from Kansas. 30 years, the cases were cold. What happened is a lawyer, in the Topeka area where he was from, wrote a book on these cases and it got some publicity, and he wanted to get credit in a sense in his own twisted mind. And so he started communicating with the police. And that will almost ensure that you're going to get caught. And in fact, he did get caught.
他们的身份以便继续杀人？我的意思是，这在多大程度上是一种动机？不，这从一开始就被过度炒作了。关于他是在戏弄警察、在玩弄调查、坐在房间里搓手之类的说法，有太多被过度炒作的成分。不，他们不想被抓住，但他们经常会做一些几乎确保自己会被抓住的事情。以堪萨斯州的BTK杀手丹尼斯·雷德（Dennis Rader）为例。30年来，这些案件一直悬而未决。后来，他家乡托皮卡地区的一位律师写了一本关于这些案件的书，并获得了一些宣传。在他扭曲的心智中，他想获得某种认可，于是他开始与警方联系。这几乎确保了他会被抓住。事实上，他确实被抓住了。
By and large, they did not want to get caught. Let me just dispel one sort of myth that you mentioned about with David Berkowitz, the son of Sam. Are they targeting people with specific characters? characteristics. That came from the 70s, and particularly the Ted Bundy investigation, because the women that he killed in the 1970s when he was operative had brown hair parted down the middle. The problem with that is if you go to a yearbook of all co-eds who were in college during the night, they all had hair, long hair parted down the middle. That was a very, very popular hairstyle back then. And so, no. Now, having said that, there is a subgroup of serial sexual murderers that will target people
总的来说，他们并不想被抓住。让我澄清一下你提到的关于大卫·伯科维茨（David Berkowitz，即“山姆之子”）的一个神话。他们是否针对具有特定特征的人？那是70年代的观点，特别是泰德·邦迪（Ted Bundy）调查案带来的影响，因为他在70年代作案时杀害的女性都有中分棕色长发。问题在于，如果你去翻看当时大学里所有女学生的年鉴，她们都留着中分长发。那是当时非常非常流行的发型。所以，并不是。话虽如此，确实有一小部分连环性杀手会针对
based on specific physical characteristics, but it's very, very rare. Most of them, it's due to their vulnerability, the victim's vulnerability and their accessibility. And it may not be as obvious as you might think. For example, yes, certainly doing things like hitchhiking and leaving a bar with a stranger. Those are all high-risk things that most women know about. But if an individual is fixated on a victim, obsessed with her, a neighbor, for example, and observes her when she goes to work, when she comes home, Wednesday night and Friday night, her boyfriend stays over. Is he going to try to abduct her on a Wednesday night or Friday night? No, because there's a male figure there. And so that type of routine behavior pattern unwittingly is a vulnerability.
具有特定身体特征的人，但这非常非常罕见。对大多数人来说，这是由于受害者的脆弱性和可接近性。这可能不像你想象的那么明显。例如，搭便车和与陌生人离开酒吧确实是大多数女性都知道的高风险行为。但如果一个人对某个受害者产生了执念，比如邻居，观察她何时上班、何时下班，周三晚上和周五晚上她男朋友会留宿。他会在周三或周五晚上尝试绑架她吗？不会，因为那里有男性在场。所以这种常规的行为模式在无意中成为了一种脆弱性。
And very few people think about that as well. Is it common for serial sexual killers also to be serial confessors? That is to confess to murders that they didn't commit. Let me break it down this way. Yes. There are some people that will confess to murders that they didn't commit to gain. notoriety and to gain a lot of status in the institution. One of my cases is not a serial sexual murder, but it's a very famous case that many people are aware of. Richard Kuclinski, the Iceman.
很少有人会想到这一点。连环性杀手也经常成为“连环供述者”吗？也就是说，承认他们没有犯下的谋杀案。让我这样分析。是的。有些人会为了获得名声并在机构中获得地位而承认自己没有犯下的谋杀案。我的一个案例不是连环性谋杀，但这是一个许多人都知道的非常著名的案例。理查德·库克林斯基（Richard Kuklinski），即“冰人”。
He is a New Jersey case, and I evaluated him when he was apprehended back in the 1980s. I never, he tells everyone he killed over 100 people. He died a couple of years ago. I never believe that. Where are all the dead people? And when he's interviewed, it becomes more and more elaborate, all these things that, no, I never believe that at all. But generally speaking, that's an aberration. I'll tell you what we did. We did a study, started to do a study of confessions in different types of crime. We know a lot about false confessions. I mean, there's been a lot of research. Many of my colleagues at John Jay did some of the seminal research on false confession. Saul Kasson, my colleague. My colleague.
他是新泽西州的案例，我在他80年代被捕时对他进行了评估。他告诉每个人他杀了100多人。他几年前去世了。我从来不相信这一点。那些死者都在哪儿？当他接受采访时，故事变得越来越复杂，所有这些事情，不，我一点也不相信。但总的来说，这是一种反常现象。我告诉你我们做了什么。我们开始对不同类型犯罪的供述进行研究。我们对虚假供述了解很多。我的许多约翰杰伊学院的同事都做过关于虚假供述的开创性研究。我的同事索尔·卡森（Saul Kassin）。我的同事
there and others as well. So we know a lot about that. But what about confessions in general? Do we know a lot about confessions? So we looked at intimate partner homicides and how they confess. And what we found is they're not confessing to the police. They're confessing to a family member. We also found eight cases where they confessed in a suicide note. So the type of confession depends upon the type of murder. what we started to do is right before the pandemic started, we looked at serial sexual murderers and their confessions. And the study was stopped in the middle due to the pandemic. Our research is now back in gear since January of this year. But for almost three years, it was shut down due to the
以及其他人也是如此。所以我们对此了解很多。但关于一般的供述呢？我们对供述了解多少？我们研究了亲密伴侣凶杀案以及他们是如何供述的。我们发现他们不是向警方供述，而是向家人供述。我们还发现了八起在遗书中供述的案例。所以供述的类型取决于谋杀的类型。在疫情开始前，我们开始研究连环性杀手及其供述。由于疫情，这项研究中途停止了。我们的研究从今年1月开始重新启动。但在近三年里，它因
pandemic. We just couldn't do anything. So we started a study on serial killers and how they confessed. And what we found is 50% of them don't confess. They say to the police, you do what you got to do, but I'm not saying a word. They're sophisticated offenders. And that gives a little bit of insight into what you just said. Now, a lot of people have violent sexual and non-sexual fantasies, but they don't act on them. Is there a precipitating factor that drives these people to actually finally act out what they've been fantasizing about.
疫情而关闭。我们什么也做不了。所以我们开始了一项关于连环杀手如何供述的研究。我们发现50%的人不供述。他们对警察说，你们该干嘛干嘛，但我一个字也不会说。他们是老练的罪犯。这让我们对你刚才说的话有了一些了解。现在，很多人有暴力的性幻想和非性幻想，但他们并没有付诸行动。是否有某种诱发因素促使这些人最终将他们幻想的事情付诸实践？
Yes. In the general population, I won't say most, but many, many people have very disturbed sexual fantasies that they keep private, even to their partner, because they're afraid if they say to their partner, I want to do this, she's going to say, what are you nuts? Do you have to see a doctor? I'm not doing that. What's the matter with you? So they keep it very much to themselves.
是的。在普通人群中，我不会说大多数，但有很多人有非常令人不安的性幻想，他们甚至对伴侣也保密，因为他们担心如果告诉伴侣“我想做这个”，对方会说“你疯了吗？你需要看医生吗？我才不干。你到底怎么了？”所以他们把这些深深地藏在心里。
same with those individuals who fantasize about killing women in this type of way. The number of people who have these perverse fantasies is much, much higher than those who actually acted out. And so why do some act it out? Well, I can say this. What we do know is that of those who do act out, there's usually some precipitate, some sort of upsetting event, such as the loss of a relationship, which means a lot to a male, the loss of a job. Men usually get some level of status from a job. In so many ways, male psychology is much more fragile than women, for example, who a job, whatever, doesn't mean all that much. And I've had
那些幻想以这种方式杀害女性的人也是如此。拥有这些变态幻想的人数远多于真正付诸行动的人。那么为什么有些人会付诸行动呢？嗯，我可以这样说。我们所知道的是，对于那些付诸行动的人，通常会有某种诱因，某种令人不安的事件，例如失去一段对男性意义重大的关系，或者失业。男性通常从工作中获得某种程度的地位。在很多方面，男性的心理比女性脆弱得多，例如，女性对工作可能没那么看重。我曾遇到
a case where the guy began killing, started his killing series when his girlfriend became pregnant. that upset him and so on. And so we can say in many cases what the precipitant is, but definitely not in all cases. And again, this requires more research and less hypothesizing and speculating and pontificating based on silence and lamps and these other sorts of things. Let me ask you about DNA evidence, which has become quite prevalent and very effective at this point, especially large-scale DNA databases that have really changed the way that police do their work. How is that changing the process of going after serial sexual killers? Well, DNA evidence and not only serial sexual murder, but all sorts of crime has just become
一个案例，那个家伙在女友怀孕时开始了杀戮系列。这让他感到不安，等等。所以我们可以在许多情况下说出诱因是什么，但绝对不是所有情况。同样，这需要更多的研究，而不是基于沉默、灯光和其他这类事情进行假设、推测和夸夸其谈。让我问你关于DNA证据的问题，它现在已经非常普遍且非常有效，特别是大规模DNA数据库，确实改变了警察的工作方式。这如何改变了追捕连环性杀手的过程？嗯，DNA证据不仅在连环性谋杀中，而且在各种犯罪中都变得
enormously, enormously helpful. Sure. You know, that this is hard science and, you know, it's very, very persuasive in court. In fact, in many, many cases, juries expect to hear DNA and other forensic evidence, you know, although in some cases you can't get DNA evidence. It's very, very difficult. I had a case where the victim was underwater for a year. And, of course, you can't get DNA evidence from that.
非常非常有帮助。当然。你知道，这是硬科学，而且在法庭上非常有说服力。事实上，在许多许多案件中，陪审团期望听到DNA和其他法医证据，尽管在某些情况下你无法获得DNA证据。这非常非常困难。我曾遇到一个案例，受害者在水下待了一年。当然，你无法从中获得DNA证据。
Unfortunately, jurors expect it. Because of the popularity of crime shows in general, the jurors are very different. today than they were 20 or 30 years ago. I had a case, I remember not that long ago, where the jury hung on a case. And after it was all over, the judge who had a good rapport with the jury said, well, what was the problem? The evidence was overwhelming. And he said, well, we all thought he did it, but there was no luminal used. Luminol is a spray that makes blood.
不幸的是，陪审员们期望得到它。由于犯罪节目的普遍流行，今天的陪审员与20或30年前大不相同。我记得不久前有一个案例，陪审团陷入了僵局。结束后，与陪审团关系良好的法官问：“问题出在哪里？证据是压倒性的。”他说：“我们都认为是他干的，但没有使用鲁米诺（Luminol）。”鲁米诺是一种能使血液显色的喷雾。
And you see it in all the shows. Right. Well, what do you think the red stuff was coming out of the dead person? That's blood. You don't have to use lumenol to determine it was blood, but they do in the shows. And so, you know, you have to be very careful now in jury selection. That's really up to the judges to voir dire these jurors to the extent that will you listen to what the judge is saying as opposed to what you heard on TV. And it's very, very hard to undo something that you've heard so many times. before. Last question, and I guess I'm going to ask you to speculate a little bit here. Why do so many people, especially women, seem to find serial sexual killers and killing so morbidly fascinating? Well, yes. I mean, they certainly do. And if you look at the crime shows like ID Discovery, and I've done so many of those, and I speak to the producers, they say 80% of their viewers are women. And in my opinion, I think it's a number of different factors. Number one, they tend to
你在所有节目中都能看到它。没错。那么你认为死者身上流出来的红色物质是什么？那是血。你不需要使用鲁米诺来确定它是血，但节目里就是这么做的。所以，在陪审团遴选时必须非常小心。这真的取决于法官是否能对这些陪审员进行预审，以确保他们会听法官在说什么，而不是听电视上听到的内容。要消除你听过很多次的事情是非常非常困难的。最后一个问题，我想请你在这里做一点推测。为什么这么多人，尤其是女性，似乎觉得连环性杀手和杀戮行为有一种病态的吸引力？嗯，是的。我的意思是，她们确实觉得。如果你看看像ID Discovery这样的犯罪节目，我参加过很多，我和制片人交谈过，他们说80%的观众是女性。在我看来，我认为这是多种因素造成的。第一，她们往往
be the victim of these cases. And they want to learn how not to become a victim because so many of these guys, particularly the guys that they feature on the crime shows, look so normal and behave so normally. That's one reason. The other reason is I think women, for example, more than men, are psychologically more interested in the complexity of the inner workings of the human mind as opposed to a guy. example, in jury selection, you have one of these cases of someone going around and mutilating women. Many guys will say, kill him. He's not a person. He's a, whereas a woman may be more empathetic, maybe more understanding, may try to understand his background, and this sort of thing. So, I mean, those are two speculative answers as to why women become, you know, involved in this.
是这些案件的受害者。她们想学习如何不成为受害者，因为这些家伙，特别是犯罪节目中出现的那些人，看起来非常正常，行为也非常正常。这是一个原因。另一个原因是，我认为女性在心理上比男性更关注人类思维内部运作的复杂性。例如，在陪审团遴选中，遇到有人到处残害女性的案件，许多男性会说：“杀了他。他不是人。”而女性可能更具同理心，可能更具理解力，可能会试图了解他的背景等等。所以，这就是为什么女性会参与其中的两个推测性答案。
I'll say one other thing as a closing thing to answer your question and a little bit different. The death of a child of one of these people is devastating for not only the family members, but the community and even the country in highly publicized cases. And I've had the opportunity over the years to speak to family members who lost a child. And in particular, you talk about the difference in men and women, in my experience, It particularly seems to affect fathers more than mothers. I mean, they're just so devastated. And I remember one father said to me, I'll never forget it.
在结束回答你的问题时，我想再说一点不同的看法。这些人的孩子死亡对家庭成员、社区甚至在高度公开的案件中对整个国家来说都是毁灭性的。多年来，我有机会与失去孩子的家庭成员交谈。特别是，你谈到男性和女性的区别，根据我的经验，这似乎对父亲的影响比对母亲更大。我的意思是，他们太崩溃了。我记得一位父亲对我说，我永远不会忘记。
He said to me, you know, if my daughter died of cancer or my daughter died in a horrible car accident, that's one thing. These things happen. But my daughter died because some guy got sexual gratification killing you. He said, I can't wrap my head around that. I just can't go on with that type of thought. And it's a very, very disturbing thought. It just really, really is. And you just can't help but feel such empathy for people and to spur us all on to try to unravel
他对我说：“你知道，如果我的女儿死于癌症或死于一场可怕的车祸，那是一回事。这些事情会发生。但我的女儿死是因为某个家伙通过杀人获得了性满足。”他说：“我无法理解这一点。我无法带着这种想法继续生活。”这是一种非常非常令人不安的想法。确实如此。你无法不为这些人感到同情，并激励我们所有人去尝试揭开
this as best we can. Also, in terms of preventing this, you know, when we see some red flags like sexual burglaries and repetitive fire setting and these sorts of things, what kind of interventions can we have from a mental health perspective to intervene and try to prevent the development of these sorts of cases. Dr. Schlesinger, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been absolutely fascinating. Thank you.
这一点，尽我们所能。此外，在预防方面，当我们看到一些危险信号，如性入室盗窃、重复纵火等行为时，我们能从心理健康的角度进行什么样的干预，以试图防止这类案件的发展？施莱辛格博士，我想感谢你今天加入我的节目。这绝对令人着迷。谢谢。
Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening.
谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。感谢您的收听。
The American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。